bonjour j'espère que vous allez bien
écoutez je viens vous parler de physique
l'électrodynamique des corps en
mouvement je viens vous parler
l'alchimie entre les corps tout est régi
par l'énergie je vais vous démontrer
tout à l'heure que certaines postures et
que certaines figures ont dépassé les
lois de la physique
quand je parle d'énergie dans cette
salle yann énergie qui circule
vous me procurer d'énergie j'ai même
besoin d'énergie là en ce moment ok
merci
voyez l'énergie c'est beaucoup de choses
j'ai mon énergie intérieure
vous avez la vôtre en ce moment elle
circule dans cette salle la sensibilité
l'émotion tout ce qui résume mouvement
le mouvement perpétuel
qu'est ce que le mouvement perpétuel
appris ça en travaillant et carolyn
carlson chorégraphe de renommée
internationale le mouvement perpétuel
il peut être à l'arrêt il peut être
ondulé mais aussi peut être saccadé mais
avant de partir dans la démonstration je
ferai pas la mairie ni réminiscences du
passé et le premier mouvement que je
vais vous démontrer
c'est un mouvement basé sur les
traditions comme on dit pour savoir où
on va il faut savoir d'où l'on vient
jeune sénégauloise comme femme sénégal
highway
m
oh
ça
alors
c'est à dire que avant de rentrer dans
le vif du sujet ça pourtant de se
présenter
vous ne connaissez abda originaire du
sénégal forcément danseur chorégraphe
mais c'est important tout ça c'est ce
qui m'a aidé aussi à transmettre des
valeurs
j'y viendrai tout à l'heure la deuxième
loi que je vous propose est le deuxième
mouvement que je vais vous présenter
c'est une danse basée sur la contraction
musculaire une dans ce qu'on appelle le
popping
ah oui
ps merci
on était en afrique on arrive aux états
unis ça c'est une danse issue des
etats-unis et plus exactement de la côte
ouest des états unis un style dans ce
qu'on appelle le popping je veux venir
tout de suite à un troisième style je
pense que c'est un style que vous avez
déjà bien distinguer je pense que dans
cette salle a beaucoup de gens qui font
partie d'une génération a chipé à choper
n'est ce pas et donc ce style de danse
qu'on appelle le breakdance et c'est
vrai que c'est un style qui s'est fait
connaître dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui on retrouve ça partout une
petite performance pour faire plaisir le
break dance
ok alors je vous ai parlé d'énergie tout
à l'heure est ce que vous sentez énergie
est ce que vous sentez que l'énergie qui
circulent je vous donne l'énergie
en tout cas vous en donner beaucoup
merci les applaudissements ça c'est pour
vous alors tous vécu toute cette
richesse
ça m'a forcément construit je lui suis
un homme est donc tout ça ça m'a donné
envie de créer une école de danse et
qu'est ce qu'il m'a donné cette
impulsion
justement c'est tendre la main à la
jeunesse parce que l'école de danse
n'didance est là aussi pour développer
l'émergence artistique de la jeunesse
vous pouvez constater des photos
derrière ce sont simplement la
réalisation est l'aboutissement d'un
travail de nos élèves
parce que l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est
de leur transmettre la transmission bien
sûr cette transmission
elle se fait par passion aujourd'hui à
plus de 600 élèves qui se croisent et
qui se côtoient pour une seule et unique
passion qu'on appelle la danse on y
danse c'est notamment l'école de la vie
mais c'est l'école de la mixité sociale
toutes les catégories
socioprofessionnelles sont présentes je
rencontre des professeurs je rencontre
des chirurgiens dentistes
je rencontre des avocats qui nous
confient leurs enfants
on parle d'éducation par la danse
un enfant qui arrive en cours de danse
et qui a je vais faire comme lui
c'est pas juste de faire comme lui c'est
d'expliquer comment arriver à ça et donc
c'est de pouvoir créer des programmes
pédagogiques adaptés à l'enfant 5 7 ans
8 11 ans 12 15 ans 16 18 et adultes
aussi comme je vous dis y'a pas d'âge
pour danser
donc si vous intéresse pour trouver à la
halle de glisse facebook and i dance
alors comme vous avez pu constater le
break dance et c'est la performance mais
c'est la rigueur c'est le dépassement de
soi voilà les valeurs qu'on essaie de
transmettre au sein de notre structure
on a réalisé et tout dernièrement un
gala de danse avec nos élèves et on a ce
retour gratifiant des parents qui j'ai
mon enfant qui a grandi qu'il n'a plus
peur de se présenter devant une foule
donc vous voyez c'est déjà une avancée
c'est déjà un pas et ce qui est
important c'est dé préparer à la scène
nos enfants il faut les faire grandir et
ton papa - un site deux enfants c'est
important
la pédagogie des poux c'est la maturité
l'exigence le travail c'est notre
mission aujourd'hui donc
vrai qu'avec notre petite structure qui
rassemble aujourd'hui beaucoup de monde
c'est important pour nous d'en parler
c'est important pour nous de de
s'accrocher à ses valeurs et nos valeurs
se résume par juste une phrase et ça
sera ma dernière phrase pour résumer un
peu l'identité d'un structure and i
dance parce que vous me voyez moi
aujourd'hui mais je ne suis pas tout
seul
les danseurs que je remercie beaucoup
qui m'ont accompagné ces des années de
travail
notre métier aujourd'hui c'est une
remise en question de tous les jours
sinon mise en question de tous les jours
parce qu'on n'a pas des contrats tous
les jours fera danser sur scène mais
c'est important d'avoir cette force
intérieure
cette positivité cette envie de partager
de vivre ensemble de s'aimer de danse et
voilà comment je me caractérise la
structure ended ans
c'est un lieu de vie où des passionnés
se croît chaque semaine pour l'amour de
la danse
voilà ma dernière phrase c'est que c'est
important d'envoyer du positif parce
qu'on en a besoin
danser c'est s'évacuer pas mal de choses
pas mal de stress mais sachez que and
ideas effectivement c'est une structure
aujourd'hui qui créent de l'emploi parce
que les professeurs qui travaillent
aujourd'hui je parlais de remise en
question de tous les jours le travail
l'exigence pour arriver à faire de telle
figure sur scène ça nécessite des heures
des heures des heures de travail en
studio et ça c'est du mérite et le fait
d'être là pour moi aussi c'est une
reconnaissance parce que je pensais
jamais faire un discours comme ça devant
autant de personnes
mais je vous remercie beaucoup vous
m'avez beaucoup aidé et juste s'il ya
quelque chose à retenir
retenez juste cette phrase l'ofs peace
unity and having fun
et
à
oh
merci merci
merci beaucoup yes
alors je vous présente quand même mon
équipe j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
rahim j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
foued
vous m'excusez j'ai fait un pont mais
c'était l'occasion pour nous aussi parce
que voilà on est solidaire est aussi un
dj l'école développement je présente
abdallah en provenance de dakar
merci beaucoup